[Musica]
Buonasera a tutte e tutti
allora Inizio subito c'è un libro di uno
scrittore che amo molto Peter che che si
chiama ma io vivo solo degli interstizi
in tedesco
si traduce degli interstizi ma a me
piace tradurlo Ma io vivo solo del tra
perché mi prendo questa licenza poetica
perché effettivamente come attrice Io
vivo solo del o forse meglio nel tra Io
sono come attrice un tramite appunto o
si dice classicamente un interprete o
come piace a me definirmi un testimone
tra un testo quindi un autore e un
pubblico sono qualcuno Insomma che a
l'altro sta tra
qui e lì
quindi
occupiamoci di questa parola che cos'è
tra sicuramente una preposizione Ma
questo lo sappiamo tutti
per quel che ci interessa qui ora tra è
uno spazio questa parolina piccolissima
ci trasporta e ci apre in uno spazio
enorme uno spazio vuoto e come sappiamo
uno spazio vuoto è la condizione perché
qualcosa si muova perché qualcosa passi
perché qualcosa
accada in ultima istanza Ecco in questo
spazio
accade il teatro Cioè per me il teatro
non è tanto l'edificio il teatro
Paisiello il teatro Petruzzelli il
teatro è lo spazio tra me e voi lo
spazio che si apre tra gli attori e gli
spettatori qui ed ora adesso
e quello che distingue questo il teatro
da un'altra forma d'arte che ha la
stessa disposizione spaziale lì ci sono
gli spettatori qui accade qualcosa è il
fatto che accada proprio qui e ora
l'altra è il cinema ovviamente qui ora
adesso
dal vivo
occupiamoci quindi di quest'altra
espressione dal vivo
mi faccio una domanda che cos'è che fa
Dio uno spettacolo dal vivo uno
spettacolo
vivo e per provare a rispondere a questa
domanda io me le devo fare un'altra Che
cosa succede se a teatro lo spazio tra
non è libero non è vuoto è occupato è
occupato dalla famosa quarta parete ora
lo saprete tutti Comunque ve lo spiego
la quarta parete è la quarta parete che
appunto chiude il palcoscenico Cioè ci
sono tre pareti reali fisiche dei
mattoni decemento e poi c'è una parete
immaginaria invisibile che è lì e che
trasforma il palcoscenico in uno spazio
chiuso separato
ora
Che cosa succede se tra noi c'è una
parete per quanto invisibile succede che
noi non siamo nello stesso spazio Noi
siamo
divisi Io sono di qua da questa parte
della parete e voi siete di là
dall'altra parte della parete e Ciò
significa che tra noi non può accadere
nulla veramente qui ed ora non è
possibile un'interazione non è possibile
un dialogo
partiamo dall'inizio voi siete entrati
vi siete Accomodati ai vostri posti io
l'attrice
ho studiato ho imparato la mia parte a
memoria
ho fatto tante prove mesi mesi
entro in scena recito Ma tra di noi ce
la quarta parete quindi io non vi prendo
assolutamente in considerazione anzi
come attrice ti dirò di più sono quasi
addestrata a non prendervi in
considerazione Io faccio finta che voi
non ci siete qui ed ora con me qualsiasi
cosa accade Io sono di qua voi siete di
là
Sono concentrata
concentrata su quello che ho da dire lo
spettacolo da mandare avanti le battute
imparate a memoria cosa può accadere tra
di noi cosa accade ma soprattutto
cosa state vedendo un pezzo di bravura
si spera E io cosa voglio da voi
la vostra ammirazione
il vostro stupore forse sicuramente alla
fine i vostri applausi Ma certamente non
non un dialogo non un'interazione ma
prendiamo
pure in considerazione questo che questo
teatro non va svalutato è un teatro il
teatro diciamo classico da quarta parete
che io non voglio svalutare esistono
esempi eccelsi E mettiamo il caso che in
questo caso ci sia uno spettacolo
meraviglioso uno spettacolo l'attrice è
bravissima la regista pure le luci sono
sono straordinarie Insomma è tutto
assolutamente
ben fatto
proprio qui il punto voi state
assistendo a qualcosa di già fatto
ben fatto ma già fatto non accade nulla
qui ora è già tutto accaduto è già tutto
accaduto durante le prove durante le
prove Ci si sono fatte delle domande si
sono fatte delle ipotesi
si è fatta della ricerca e alla fine si
è costruito
confezionato uno spettacolo che è quello
che vi si presenta
Ma mettiamo pure e questo è uno
spettacolo dal vivo Certamente io sono
viva e voi presumibilmente pure però
c'è qualche dubbio no Supponiamo
Allora però che questo sia uno
spettacolo moderno Allora io che faccio
io Atletico Balzo
vengo da voi cioè invado il vostro
spazio lo spazio degli spettatori Vi
guardo negli occhi
magari vi tocco pure Eh insomma sono qui
la quarta parete è stata abbattuta lo ha
battuto abbattuta io passando di qua
Eppure può succedere
stranamente che continui a non accadere
nulla veramente qui ed ora
Come mai
questo accade se io attrice attore
riempio quel vuoto quello spazio
lasciato libero dall'abbattimento della
quarta parete con il cemento della mia
interpretazione come se vi offrissi una
tesi senza possibilità di
contraddittorio io attrice attore
opero una tale occupazione militare del
testo che voi non avete nessuna
possibilità di pensare in autonomia
perché
ritorno dall'altra parte della parete
Perché che cosa è successo Ho abbattuto
la quarta parete ma ne ho costruita una
che ne so la quinta la sesta con tutta
la mia bravura la mia interpretazione la
mia tesi definitiva
a questo punto è tutto già accaduto e
tutto già stato pensato anche qui anche
in questo caso manca di nuovo il dialogo
manca di nuovo l'interazione ora per
interazione a teatro io non intendo il
teatro interattivo Nel senso che adesso
io prendo te Federico ti faccio salire
sul palco ti do un copione e ti
costringo a recitare Cioè queste sono
possibilità di interazione che si usano
nella performance contemporanea
Ma che io personalmente non non adopero
e non amo
Perché Ma perché credo che non che non
occorre io non credo che occorra
costringere il pubblico a recitare
perché il teatro sia interattivo
Io credo Semmai che basti perché il
pubblico il pubblico e dice il teatro
Scusate è già interattivo di per sé se
quello che accade accade veramente qui
ed ora e
forse
vi stupirò O forse non vi stupirò
Comunque forse non c'è bisogno nemmeno
di abbattere del tutto la quarta parete
Ma basta lasciare che in questa parete
si formi Una crepa La Crepa dalla quale
per citare Leonard Cohen passa la luce
ora da questa crepa E questa crepa Se io
sono io attrice o attore sono il tramite
sono
l'interprete questa crepe è come se
passasse esattamente attraverso di me
nello spazio della crepa in questo caso
accade il dialogo ma
vi chiederete Vabbè c'è la parete seppur
crepata però tu hai detto niente
interazione col pubblico quindi Ma che
cos'è che può veramente accadere
qui E ora cosa di nuovo cosa di
imprevisto che cosa ma soprattutto dove
perché forse l'avrete capito Io sono un
po' fissata con gli spazi dove accadono
le cose
è uno spazio immateriale né più né meno
come la quarta parete
qui Qui
è nel pensiero può accadere di pensare È
come se dalla dalla crepa io
attore attrice mi lasciassi guardare e
mi esponessi Sì nella mia vulnerabilità
nel fatto di essere viva qui e ora
Pensante qui e ora e
questo farmi vedere in trasparenza e non
nascondere Le possibili errori come mi
ha detto sempre il fisico e perché lui
ha detto che l'evoluzione è fatta di
errori quindi io sto a posto ne sto
facendo un sacco quindi mi sto evolvendo
e
[Musica]
nello spazio quindi in questo spazio è
come se io dicesse Beh fate come me
pensate anche voi non date nulla per
scontato non non affidatevi alla mia
interpretazione perché non è l'unica
possibile e non è immortale Io sono
mortale Io sono viva Non faccio teatro
immortale faccio teatro mortale Brecht
diceva trovate lo strano anche se
consueto io dico
pensatelo nuovo Anche se consueto ecco
quando io attore Non erigo una quarta
parete non solo e non tanto tra il
palcoscenico e la platea ma proprio
dentro di me tra quello che dico e
quello che penso tra il mio pensare il
mio sentire e il testo e sono pronta qui
a scoprire ogni sera cosa si nasconde
dietro le parole sono pronta a scoprire
ogni sera qualcosa di nuovo e sono
pronta a lasciarmi questa libertà che mi
rende estremamente vulnerabile e sono
pronta a lasciarvela a voi per pensare
da voi questo è un concetto lessiano a
cui io tengo tantissimo ma lasciamo
perdere perché sono famosa per le
deviazioni
e quando lascio quelli aperta e
percorribile lo spazio del tra La Crepa
tra le parole La Crepa tra me e quello
che dico tra una parola e l'altra tra me
il testo tra voi e il testo tra me e voi
quando non voglio ottenere un effetto
sempre lo stesso sempre allo stesso
punto Perché è la stessa libertà che
lascio a me se io stasera Magari mi
commuovo in un punto che ieri mi aveva
lasciato indifferente e anche voi magari
non è detto che vi commoriate in quel
punto che a me sembrava così
incredibilmente commovente E magari
riderete in un punto dove io non me lo
sarei mai aspettato Ecco questo è uno
spettacolo vivo il teatro che mi
interessa è un teatro vivo e mortale è
un teatro che attraverso per esempio il
testo di Antigone quello sì immortale e
non non vi presenta
Antigone con la mia
interpretazione come la migliore
definitiva e immortale interpretazione è
un teatro che attraverso il testo di
Antigone è come se cercasse appunto di
aprire una crepa Una crepa che
attraverso quella parete che a teatro si
chiama quarta parete Ma esiste anche
fuori dal teatro e si chiama bolla si
chiama
conformismo pensiero mainstream si
chiamano confini nazionali ma un'altra
deviazione
e attraverso quella crepa vi invita a
pensare il teatro è un atto del pensiero
è un pensiero che accade qui ed ora E
per concludere 2 minuti poi mi sparano
dalla regia e per concludere qui ed ora
vi voglio lanciare un
sassolino quando vado a al cinema e la
sala e semivuota penso Wow ho la sala
tutta per me che meraviglia
quando vado a teatro e la sala e semi
vuota
mi assale un senso di disagio
perché
Io provo a dare una risposta ma poi voi
magari ne troverete delle altre forse
forse
perché
a teatro io non vado solo per fruire di
qualcosa
forse perché a teatro vado per prendere
parte a qualcosa che accade e accade qui
e ora
sempre che
sia uno spettacolo vivo e non solo dal
vivo grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]